hello everyone i'm gerald and today we
are going to be checking out the benq
mobius ex3210u
and if you are like me looking for
gaming monitor at the style 2022 this
moderator might have popped up on your
radar after all if you have a 3080 gpu
or equivalent or even better 4k gaming
is pretty much on the cards and this
monitor could be at the top of your list
however if your heart is set on the benq
mobius ex3210u
you might want to hold on to that taut a
bit longer there are plenty of gaming
monitors coming out this year that could
match or better this current monitor
depending on where you live an lg oled
tv might make more sense than a gaming
monitor as a whole but what makes this
gaming monitor worth its wow and that's
the question we're trying to answer
today before we begin do consider liking
and subscribing to our channel if you
found this video helpful it really helps
us go a long way and keeps us doing the
things that we love
okay folks let's talk specs the benq
mobius ex3210u
is a 32 inch 4k ips display that comes
in a 16 by 9 aspect ratio in addition to
that modern console owners such as folks
who own a ps5 or xbox series x this
monitor comes with two hdmi 2.1 ports
and finally we have a displayport 1.4
for the pc master race box on top of
that we have a generous spread of power
usb ports here so you're able to hook up
plenty more accessories via the monitor
with extremely thin bezels at the top
and at this side we are looking at a
gaming monitor that looks really sleek
check it out
if you're looking for a display that's
top of the line specs
this is one monitor you should have on
top of your list
however don't pull the trigger just yet
the biggest concern here is that the
monitor is not g-sync supported so your
mileage may vary
however it does support free sync
so you still have that option in order
to enjoy optimal frame rates that your
gpu can provide even if you're not using
an amd card
if you're new to the channel i will be
reviewing all upcoming monitors and
existing monitors on my ergotron hx desk
mount
this gives me the flexibility
when adjusting the display and getting
to the ports under the monitor
while the arm is expensive it's great
and holds displays up to a weight of the
dkg for the benq mobius ex3210u
i've had to remove some screws as the
rear is curved in order for me to fit my
visa adapter
unlike the lg c1 i found that the
placements for ports or monitors are
still a bit awkward especially if you
are like us that will be plugging
systems in and out frequently
honestly how often will you guys be
actually plugging in and out your cables
anyway
just be mindful of the height and flex
plus slack of any cables that's running
from under the monitor
if you're the type of person who loves
to keep a neat desk this is something to
be mindful of
and talking about tiny desk here's a
word from our sponsor here at geek
culture we love our keyboards especially
with the all new logitech mx keys mini
an elegant and functional keyboard its
ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the backlights turned off to find
out more about the logitech mx keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com
back to the display i've used this
monitor on its maximum 3840 by 2160
resolution and i found that the ips
display is consistent across the other
benq monitors i've reviewed for anyone
looking to get this monitor or
controlling a4k monitor in general
you'll probably want to use it for all
things gaming
because with the hdmi 2.1 and
displayport 1.4 you'll be getting
maximum frames for your hardware and
enjoying the power of the variable
refresh rate when playing games
considering that this is a 144hz monitor
you want to get as many frames as
possible for the smoothest visuals
it's all plug and play for this monitor
and it comes calibrated out of the box
it does warrant mentioning that they
need some level of setup when it comes
to getting the hdr working optimally on
the display itself while benq does come
with a few preset options it doesn't
seem to look quite right no matter how
the various toggles are tweaked
considering that you already might have
a gpu ideal for this monitor what i
found is opting for windows owned hdr
settings is the ideal way to go
otherwise if you are using benq's own
simulated hdr options it will result in
sub-optimal content calibration that
might affect your overall experience
depending on the content which does not
support hdr natively many otherwise i'll
say i love how benq includes a
controller with all their top end
displays which makes it easier to get to
these settings instead of having to
fiddle around with the buttons under the
monitor so at this point if you're
someone who's very particular at how the
monitor actually looks especially when
it comes to color i would recommend you
go down to the store to take a look at
this monitor in the flesh
otherwise you might need to grab someone
to help you calibrate it to your
specific needs
aside from that this is the mobius line
from benq and so it is tailored for
gaming
we've tried it with horizon forbidden
west on the ps5 and when the action
heats up there's no noticeable slowdown
or screen tearing at all
as ailoy journeys across the forbidden
rest you can't help but marvel how well
the monitor and ps5 is able to tap on
each other strings to get the most out
of each other's hardware when it comes
to pc gaming it becomes trickier
on titles such as doom for hdr support
it does make the game look overly tuned
up
with more recent titles such as dynalite
2 the monitor performs brilliantly on 4k
and of course benq has a special dying
light team monitor for this model as
well
so if you're a fan of the game and
looking to upgrade your gear benq has
you covered apart from the display benq
has been placing greater emphasis on
their inbuilt trevolo 2.1 channel
speakers
which is good
just in case all your hardware budget
went into your gpu
and your monitor audio wise the speakers
work well for most types of content
and you can't really find any fault with
this as it adds a good amount of value
to the monitor
[Applause]
that being said there is even a sound
isolating microphone which allows you to
use these speakers and the mic at the
same time
however if you're like us
you probably already have a headset
and microphone already set up i'm saying
when it comes to the benq mobius
ex321gou the biggest concern that most
people will have will be the area above
price
it will be priced at 1099 us dollars and
considering that right now we are at the
start of 2022 there will be even more
monitors rolling out for what is worth
it does come with 4k high refresh rates
hdmi 2.1
a bit more investment down the line in
could very well lend you an oled display
with that said our recommendation is to
really wait it out this is not a bad
display by any measure but we still have
a full year to run thanks for sticking
around to the end of this video let me
know if you have any thoughts about the
benq mobius tx3210u
gaming monitor i'll be able to help you
answer any of your questions in the
comment section below with that it i'm
gerald please consider liking and
subscribing to our channel because i
will be reviewing a lot more gaming
monitors as the year rolls on and i'll
see you in the next one
[Music]